manque de considération restrictions
budgétaires dégradation des soins
les revendications des infirmiers sont
multiples et s'accentue avec la crise du
coc vite 19 un malaise
décrit par la profession depuis les
années 60 on voudrions une meilleure
organisation de travail nos tâches ont
mêlé sont embrouillées il n'y a pas de
différence entre une servante une aide
soignante une infirmière aussi bien aux
yeux du médecin qu aux yeux de
l'administrateur à cette époque la
profession presque exclusivement
féminine entame sa quête de
reconnaissance
les valeurs de dévouement et de charité
qui définissent le métier depuis
longtemps ne suffisent plus en 1966
cette infirmière décrivait la réalité de
son travail et le travail est absolument
épuisant les horaires sont très mauvais
d'autre part le salaire c'est n'est pas
du tout en conséquence le travail
deux ans plus tard en 1968 sept autres
infirmières dénoncé les pressions
budgétaires et le manque d'effectifs ou
marchands toute l'année avec le même nom
c'est à dire s'il n'y a pas de maladie
tout va bien mais c'est une maladie qu
ses jours de repos complet dans les
années soixante dix la profession passe
à l'action
c'est désormais dans la rue que les
infirmiers hospitaliers et libéraux
veulent se faire entendre
en 1978 pour la première fois une loi
reconnaît aux infirmiers une autonomie
dans les soins mais les conditions de
travail ne change pas vraiment en 1988
le mouvement de grève est nationale et
leurs revendications sont toujours les
mêmes les infirmières aujourd'hui en ont
assez soutenue par plusieurs professions
du secteur sanitaire elles ont exprimé
aujourd'hui leur colère dans la rue ou
sur leur lieu de travail tout en
assurant les services une grève très
suivie pour obtenir une véritable
reconnaissance de leurs diplômes et des
conditions dans lesquelles elles
assurent ce travail
les réformes de santé se succèdent mais
les infirmiers ne se sent toujours pas
prises en compte par les pouvoirs
publics
un sentiment de mal être renforcée à
l'été 2016 après le suicide de 5
soignants nous organisions travail at
elle réellement le pied chez vous des
agents d'une façon très violente un peu
comme à france télécom malheureusement
et on a on a peur d'avoir d'avoir une
série de suicides au dessus de cet ordre
là ces derniers mois la grogne des
infirmiers n'a pas faibli et cela malgré
le ségur de la santé lancée en mai
dernier le malaise persiste dans la
profession un malaise qui dure depuis
plus de 50 ans
[Musique]